[Musique]
dans la soirée du mardi 19 décembre le
président du conseil départemental Cyril
Melchor a lancé les festivités du Grand
20 décembre au domaine de villel au côté
du préfet de la Réunion l'invité
d'honneur de cette 6e édition était la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur de
la technologie et de l'innovation de la
République de namiie pays avec lequel le
département a engagé un travail
d'unification des mémoires de
l'esclavage
comme chaque année les commémorations
ont débuté par la libération des chaînes
des esclaves dans la chapelle
[Musique]
pointue sans son suivi l'ouverture et la
visite du
camp l'inauguration de l'exposition code
NOIR et le fleurissement du Mémorial
situé à côté de l'ancien hôpital des
esclav
le message que je voudrais formuler
c'est bonne fête à toutes mais surtout
n'oublions pas n'oublions pas notre
histoire n'oublions pas nos souffrances
celle de de ceux qui étaient là avant
nous et
évitons aux nouvelles générations de
connaître des abominations comme
l'esclavage le combat est permanent
c'est pour cela que le Conseil
départemental organise ce grand 20
décembre c'est un acte mémoriel mais
c'est aussi un acte d'espoir pour
transmettre un message aux nouvelles
générations des festivités bien
évidemment rythmées par des temps
musicaux et des explications sur les
découvertes réalisées sur le site de cet
ancien domaine colonial appelé à être
transformé en musée de l'habitation et
de l'esclavage à l'horizon
[Musique]